what has zendaya smiling so big her man
tom holland of course
it's amazing the actress visits tom on
the set of his new show the crowded room
in manhattan she's rocking an all-black
two-piece ensemble with her hair down in
soft waves
no sighting of tom he was probably busy
working but we have to imagine he's
feeling the love but fans of the couple
will recall back in april it was the
other way around when tom visited his
girlfriend where she was working the two
were spotted cuddled up in boston where
zendaya was filming her movie
challengers i think it's great to have
that support and that love around you
because you need that you know this
isn't an easy easy job so it's good to
have
that too to free you up from it every
now and then and the love between these
spider-man co-stars seems to be going
strong
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there just last month
zendaya spilled this cute secret about
tom to their spiderman no way home
co-star andrew garfield
he was so nervous and
cause like you know he's like i don't
want to step on anyone's toes and i
don't want anybody to like i just like
that me and toby were like that we were
like we don't want to step on
tom's like this is tom's movie it's your
guys movie and as things between the two
continue to blossom the famously private
pair has shared more and more about
their relationship like for tom's
birthday last month zendaya posted this
sweet tribute writing quote happiest of
birthdays to the one who makes me the
happiest
and back in september tom did a birthday
post of his own sharing this sweet pick
for z's 25th very sweet post from tom
what was it like to see the post and i
noticed you commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
um um yeah no i um i appreciated you
know the love that i got from my loved
ones and then also from you know the
world it was i felt incredibly loved and
grateful for for all of that so you know
i have no complaints it was a great
birthday but it hasn't always been that
way
last july when the duo was trying to
keep their love under wraps a paparazzo
photographed them kissing in a car
and just days later zendaya stayed super
coy about the whole thing that's
pictures of you and tom and people were
so excited because they're like
spider-man mj it's real like it was like
the world was rooting for this moment
well i'm i'm excited for the film to
come out i can't wait for everybody to
see
um spiderman when it does come out and
you know we we all work so hard we're
all so you know we're all so close from
that but even years before that they
downplayed that anything was going on
like in 2017 shortly after spider-man
homecoming was released you know i love
that you're so open about those pesky
dating rumors with tom holland in this
issue why was it important for you to be
like hey guys come on this is like my
best friend well because i mean it
happens all the time and of course you
know we we expected it i mean it's it's
um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good thankfully
in 2022 they're now more comfortable
sharing spidey snippets of their love
how are you feeling about that and
tackling that they're losing things i
think zendaya just sounds like xander
just showed up
yeah tom in awe of his leaning lady is
something we'll never stop swooning over
[Music]
you